if I remember avenges the Russo brothers
are like so here you're standing here
and you're fighting this guy and just do
whatever like okay Who am I fighting
like well we can't tell you because it's
a secret okay so what does he look like
and like well we can't tell you because
I'll give it away I'm okay so what does
he how big is he you know well we can't
tell you because that would give it away
so our just standing there punching the
air for 15 minutes and when I took the
job I didn't think that's what I would
be doing but uh but you know I've got
used to it now when you're ready let you
try that on and I'll introduce the world
the newest official member of the
Avengers spider-man hey everybody so
I've been getting a lot of requests to
do a video for iron spider costume
during infinity war like actual comic
book iron spider not just the iron
spider of the MCU that we've been
calling his suit so far like the stark
tech suit both of them are stark tech
but the infinity war suit is like legit
stark tech because it looks like metal
Ironman armor which is very close to
comic book iron spider but if you're
finding me for the first time there is
an Infinity Gauntlet giveaway that's
going on right now all you have to do to
enter it just be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video so even if you
haven't been combing the internet day or
night looking for what special functions
this suit has that are upgrades from the
previous version of the costume
obviously I think we can assume that it
still has suit lady like Karen probably
gets transplanted into it because even
though it started out like more of a
comedy thing having Jennifer Connelly
the wife of Jarvis in real life the
person who used to be Tony Stark's AI is
just too fun in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's like a fun Easter Egg but
it's also really nice too she has a
really nice voice if he goes back to the
cloth suit for the second homecoming
movie after Avengers 4 I think that suit
lady will jump into each version of the
suit
it'll be like Iron Man and Friday for
the last several movies he's had the
same AI even though he's had several
different versions of the costume but I
think the question everyone's really
asking is will it actually have the iron
spider arms because people have been
looking at the Lego sets and trying to
use those as benchmarks for what they
might and might not do just remember
that Lego sets aren't always 100
accurate they give you an idea for
things but there were a whole bunch of
thor ragnarok toys for Sekar that had
absolutely nothing to do with the stuff
that we actually saw in the movie but
that being said yeah hundred percent I
definitely think that he has the iron
spider arms from the actual comic book
version of the costume even though the
MCU version looks a little more classic
colors I think they did that from a
branding reason like they want him to
feel like classic spider-man while at
the same time doing all the coolest
stuff from the comics that they could
possibly do in the actual iron spider
comic book costume looks more like an
Iron Man costume the burnt orange and
gold just don't feel like a spider-man
costume and because this is gonna be the
biggest movie on the planet this next
year they want you to see spider-man and
think spider-man they don't want you to
think spider-man in an Iron Man costume
you see what looks like the serrated
plates it's possible that this is kind
of like the briefcase Iron Man suit that
forms around him a little bit obviously
it's a very lightweight version of an
Iron Man costume my initial guess is is
there's a piece that it forms out of it
probably sits on his back because that
would be the most spider-man thing ever
to have your costume form around you
from something on your back and if
they're gonna do the comic book arms
from the iron spider suit the arms would
come out of his back too so you'd have
to have a little piece that those could
come out from but if you look at how big
he is and how thin the suit is I'm
guessing that whatever arms he would
manifest they're mostly used for
stabilization like you don't know how
dexterous they could be he would
actually have to tell suit lady what he
wanted to use them for like suit lady
grab on to that with the arms or there
have to be some sort of automatic
function but I don't think they've taken
it so far that he has neurological
control and they work like extensions of
his own body like he can't just think
grab onto that with those arms there's
not enough time to explain him learning
how to use those there'd have to be some
kind of crazy montage and typically the
way that they surprise you with new
technology is like with the suit lady
surprise during homecoming there's a ton
of other social systems in here hmm but
they're all disabled by the training
wheels protocol
good evening Peter hello hello
congratulations on completing the
rigorous training wheels protocol in
gaining access to your suits full
capabilities oh thank you so where would
you like to take me tonight I put a
tracker on someone you didn't know that
there was an AI in the suit until they
hacked into it and turned off the
training wheels protocol and then he
just put the suit on and it
automatically turned on like Oh surprise
there's actually an artificial
intelligence in here the spider-man
timeline of the movie just sounds like
it's him having a normal day in Queens
on his way to school just thinking about
the next cool adventure that he wants to
have with Tony Stark and the Avengers
when his spidey sense goes off the
charts he sees the ship over Manhattan
makes a beeline for that and then at
some point they're gonna have to explain
how he gets this new version of this
suit because obviously there's a lot
that happens between him being on the
bus and him jumping onto this ship so
I'm guessing that everybody makes a
beeline for the sanctum sanctorum
because you see Tony's start there with
everyone else
spider-man probably meets up with them
and Tony is responsible for having the
suit come to them like he would have to
tell one of his drones to bring the suit
otherwise it wouldn't really make sense
like at the end of homecoming the whole
deal was is he's like I'm not ready for
that I just want to be the friendly
neighborhood spider-man he gives him
back the normal version of the costume
and that's the end of it he's just gonna
continue using that while he learns to
be all the spider-man that he can be so
it really does sound like spider-man is
gonna be a big part of that sanctum
battle like obviously there's all the
ebony maw stuff the time gem because
that's what they're really coming to the
sanctum for so I'm guessing there's just
a whole bunch of stuff in the trailers
that we have not seen yet so I wouldn't
be surprised if when he's jumping onto
this ship here and he stands up the arms
actually fold out and it's this big hero
shot it's just that they haven't added
it to the trailer because that requires
a lot of extra CG in it's kind of a
spoiler so it's probably a Thor Ragnarok
situation where they cut the trailer and
they just omit a couple of things just
to leave you in wonder like I wonder
what this is gonna be like but let me
know in the comments do you actually
think that when he's slowly standing up
here in this ultra hero pose this is
like the most trailer shot moment
ever that his arms pop out of his back
because look at all this negative space
like normally in a frame you would have
all this other stuff behind him but this
is just dead space waiting for something
to fill it and what better to fill it
than eight badass spider arms it just
feels like a really easy slam dunk holy
crap moment that people will be talking
about after the movie like you remember
when he jumped onto the ship and his
iron spider arms came out and he didn't
realize that he had those but that also
makes you wonder to hear when Thanos
grabs him after he jumps at him in
midair and slams into the ground if
they'll also add iron spider arms all
crumpled behind him but there was a
scene at the Comic Con footage that
hasn't made it as a trailer yet where
he's doing that Civil War thing where
he's like I'm sorry mr. stark and iron
man starts freaking out because he's so
worried don't you wonder if when he's
crying into this hand here if he's
actually holding Peters hand I know
there are a lot of theories about Pepper
Potts wearing the Iron Man armor during
this Thanos battle but simplest
explanation is is it's just a bunch of
Avengers get their asses handed to them
and he's just really upset so it's
possible that someone has died in this
scene but like I said there's a new
round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
I'll announce the winner from this video
the next time I post Marvel but
congratulations to the winner from the
last video Sergio Mercado please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here to watch that
Avengers infinity war panel where they
talk about x-men and Wolverine crossover
and click here for brand new black
panther thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]